Italy's Farm Lobby says Heavy Rain on
flooding has caused incalculable damage
to land in the north at least 13 people
have been killed while ten thousand more
have been displaced by the storm
we have other Hamid who's joining us now
from near Imola in northeastern Italy so
that's being described as Italy's worst
flooding in a hundred years how
extensive is the damage
well actually we've been traveling
around the Villages here in the area in
Emilia Emilia Romania rather and I have
to say that you know what we see over
and over again is more or less like this
treats completely flooded there are
people who are still in their houses and
we did see the Civil protection
going to them trying to get them either
out or bring them food and water now we
went to other Villages where there is no
for example network coverage whatsoever
there is no electricity we saw people
queuing by water tankers because also
the water treatment plant in the area
has been completely flooded and then we
went to a village called Santa Agata and
there people described that they had
water up to one meter one me
1.6 meters in their house we saw them
really shoveling all their belongings
into the mud quite a disastrous scene uh
to witness in this part of the country
and people are actually quite angry
because they say that rescue is coming
quite late and also they blame the poor
infrastructure that is around this area
okay we'll let you go for now thank you
for that update from Italy